thank you everybody for for hopping in
uh the idea here today is really just to
go over the options profile um like I
said in the blur and I'm going to go go
over it from a few different
perspectives um and then we're going to
look at uh something that actually
happened this morning which despite the
fact that today's Opex and in theory um
you know zero DTE is a little bit less
influential influential sorry um still
seemed to pan out pretty well this
morning
um so yeah I mean starting from the top
right uh if you guys read in the
documentation like and I'd really
recommend going through some of this
stuff um I know it's some of it's a
little bit dry but um it really is some
of the best uh the best way we found so
far to summarize this stuff in
particular this practice document which
is pretty
concise um but you know if you don't
like to do that that's kind of why I'm
here for this uh in any case
um what we're doing with options profile
which is pretty simple is we're using an
algorithm to classify incoming volume so
we're thinking about like time and sales
here as either bought or sold right so
um if a transaction comes through time
in sales we for every single transaction
that comes through we're saying whether
we think uh it was a buy or a sell and
um the the clever among you will object
that well for every buyer there is a
seller and for every seller there is a
buyer um the typical account for this is
to say well that may be true but in
order for a transaction to take place
somebody has to be the aggressor meaning
that somebody has to cross the spread
somebody has to be more willing to make
that transaction than the other guy um
and we also think about this in a
different way if you take a look at uh
metrics in the resources tab um I talk
about this as uh unmatched volume
meaning that or unmatched
inventory um so what I mean by that is
um there are cases in in the majority of
cases right whenever a transaction takes
place uh and uh a market maker right is
the intermediary um what they want to do
is they want to profit off of the spread
and then um match uh a buyer and a
seller as quickly as possible and then
pass that inventory off so they don't
have to worry about holding on to it
and what we're really trying to measure
here um sorry let me get back into state
is um in what cases uh is there
unmatched inventory meaning are is there
inventory that um that the uh that the
dealer is for forced to hold on to
because they don't find somebody
immediately on the other side for that
right so that's another way to think
about what it means for something to be
bought or sold um and once a transaction
goes through and we can tell whether
it's bought or sold
um and it's bought or sold in that
unmatched way meaning that there was
excess right there was an aggressor um
then we can start to say okay well um
how many over the course of the day
right so uh for instance like if I'm
looking at this call strike up here at
4,300 um what this is telling me right
when I hover over here and I see
classified volume call
3020 um it's telling me that our system
has uh noted
3,020 more buys than sells at this level
so in other words we're netting it out
um but we're not netting out calls and
puts right we're just netting out bought
calls versus sold calls and in this
particular case it looks like there are
more bought calls over the course of the
day so far at 4,300 than sold calls um
I'm going to take a second there do
people have questions so far about that
and I promise this will get a little
more fun when we get into the actual
tradable side of it
all right I guess I can keep going cool
so um to run through once we have that
in mind what we're really talking about
right over here 4,300 3,000 bought calls
if we hop over here 4265 around 4,000
sold calls um and this is all from the
perspective of the customer right uh and
there's a reason that we did this it's
because whenever you look at something
like uh volume profile or something like
that right um you're looking at the
overall positioning of the market we
want to know what Market participants
are doing doing right and this is a
little bit contrary to like a lot of the
literature that you see out there in
terms of dealer exposure and gex and
that's because um I don't really care so
much right about and like yes you can
infer from this what the dealers are
doing you could um but that's not my
main priority my main priority here is
to figure out well um what are people
doing right like how are people
positioned and so if I were to get a
broad overview I'll run through it one
more time right uh 3,000 bot calls at
4,300 uh around 4,000 sold calls at
4265 around let's say 2500 bought puts
at
4215 and then 42 uh 30 has around uh
let's say around 3,000 sold puts right
and so these are all customer positions
right and so I can tell you already just
by looking at this um people that are TR
in the SPX today that are trading
options on the on the SPX are expecting
um and this is I mean my tweet from the
other day um they're expecting a range
between 4265 and uh
4230 um I can also tell you off the bat
that there is decreas in confidence that
this is going to be the bottom of the
range for the day it probably still will
be but there's decreas in confidence and
you can tell because you know these sold
puts at 4230 are bailing right now um
and that kind of gets me into the dots
that we covered in the uh instructional
video or visualizations video which is
right this tells us where we were 30
minutes ago so we can say that 30
minutes ago there were 4,000 uh sold
puts over here and then uh five minutes
ago there were um 3,500 so that means
that in the last five minutes they've
bailed out of about what is that about a
thousand of these contracts in other
words they've been buying back about a
thousand of these uh 4230 puts right um
of itself is like a pretty decent point
of information
um and so you can start to blend
together right um that time component I
mean another just to just to give you
guys another example right if I look up
here at the 4300s I can say that oh wow
right like earlier in the day they were
in more of these and then in the last
five minutes you know they've gotten out
of about a thousand of them which makes
sense right like what's the likelihood
that we're getting up there um when we
were um actually let me hop into
orderflow just to show a little a little
bit of price action here but um when we
were coming up here and this is actually
we we came up and touched vwap on yes
most likely they were still holding on
to those um and then they probably took
that as an opportunity to get out
because the likelihood that you know
these options are going to be worth
anything by the end of the day is very
very low right um so they probably took
on that
opportunity all right cool so now that
we have kind of like a basic idea of
what all this stuff means we kind of
like think get a little bit more
interesting in terms of how to read it
um and the cool thing is that it's like
I've been talking to so many different
people that have started to use this and
um depending on their level of expertise
and their like whether they think in
terms of like price action and
positioning or whether they think in
terms of volatility people tend to have
a different uh take on what's going on
here right like our priority is just to
show you guys the positioning and then
over time as you watch the price action
you can learn um to see it in your own
way that being said right I'm not I'm
not against um providing sort of an like
a guide to to using it because I've
spent a lot of time watching this
obviously and and and and there's some
benefit in that um so there's a few
different ways that I think about this
um and the simplest way to be honest is
just to think about it like a giant
volume profile so for those of you that
trade futures or even equities a lot of
times you'll have a volume profile on
the right of your chart um
and there are certain behaviors that are
quite characteristic of volume profile
um and that is and and the main Behavior
I'd say that's characteristic is that um
when we have a very large node um that
tends to be a point where we stall out
and we also tend to Traverse territory
where there's not very much uh like
aggregation of positions quicker than we
do when there's a high density of
positions right um so let me actually
load history for the day so maybe we can
find a better example of
this um and then I'll get into the
difference between long and short
positioning which is where this gets a
little more interesting than than just
volume profile um but basically you know
if you see a very very large node then
um that is a good point to either look
for reversion or a breakout in some
direction um and if you see especially
if you see territory Beyond it that is
very thinly populated because like let's
get back into what does that mean right
so from a like from a purely um how
would I put it non options perspective
right um if somebody sold you know 2,000
of these 4230s that means they're
willing to buy the market at that strike
um so when you look down and you see
this like dense population of sold puts
here here here here like all the way
down it means we essentially have limit
buy orders underneath the market all the
way down here
right um
um and then and then in the same way
right um when you have somebody selling
calls right um they're saying that if
price gets Above This level it's just
basically a limit sell it's like I'm
short the market above 4265 right um and
so you can understand it in that way
right from it's kind of like a Futures
uh Traders understanding of what's going
on here and these are just the short
options in terms of the long options
right um it's people who are uh you know
willing to buy the market here 4,300 for
instance um or people who are willing to
short the market here at 4215 because
these are long foots right um and so you
know what I would kind of encourage if
you start to think about it that way you
can kind of get a sense for um it
becomes kind of more like a puzzle right
it's like what is the overall
positioning adding up to um where are
the um where are the holes where are the
vulnerabilities the one thing that that
Futures based uh thinking doesn't quite
do is uh work in the time Dimension um
but that's something that we can we can
definitely and and we will get
to um all right let me find one of those
examples from earlier today and I'll
slow down a little bit I have a tendency
to go a little quick through this stuff
but yeah let me know if you guys have
questions like I'll answer them on the
go um and uh yeah so feel free to
ask I can't I can't let people on the
stage to speak because I don't have OBS
set up for that but if you guys type out
questions I'm I'm watching right
now
okay
so here's a really really simple trade
actually from earlier today which is
probably a good starting
point um which is as we were coming down
today right towards this we've been
talking about this 4230
level as we were coming down um there
was this like pretty interesting uh
inflection point where um and let me let
me move back down there so you can see
as we were coming down they started
getting into or they when I say they by
the mean I just I just mean traders in
general right um I know that that's sort
of uh there's a lot of um superstition
about that term that's all I mean
anyways as as price was coming down you
can see right price is this white line
spot price um and and there were they
started adding to short puts right here
and then long puts over here and long
puts right here right um and in general
what that tells me as we're doing that
is wow right like these levels
underneath us are building up um so I
started to get a lot more bullish as we
were coming down into this range the one
issue here
right um and we all know what happened
right but the one issue as we were
coming down here
oh a second here okay um was this this
time and like in terms of actually
trading it like this was a pretty
intense time and you you guys can see by
the way we're squeezing now and we're
going to get into why that's happening
but um during this period right we were
trapped between that 4235 long puts and
4230 short puts right so this is kind of
like a ton of people saying hey I'm
willing to buy the market down here at
4230 and there were a ton of other
people who were short at
4235 and so the way to think about this
is if we get enough um momentum or
conviction in the sense of people
getting underneath and selling puts
under the market and being like hey I'm
willing to buy to the point that we can
break above these 42 35s these people
are going to become trapped shorts and
we're going to be able to squeeze up um
and it took a while right like we were
bouncing around for a while between um
4230 and 4235 until eventually we were
able to hold above the 4235 level and
once that starts to happen these people
start to bail and you can see it because
there are these like Dots here
right um and so as the bar shrinks right
um and we can see that the dots are
outside the bar it means that these guys
are bailing so these long puts are
bailing um and as those long puts bail
it actually clears the way for us to
continue
upwards um and once that starts to
happen actually we have this Dynamic
right where um the way I would
categorize this or like characterize
this profile is if we had fallen below
4230 we had a pretty clear path all the
way down to 4215 no question right
because the the the sort of um the
effect of all these puts like all of a
sudden there's a lot of trap traders who
essentially said hey I'm willing to buy
at 4230 and then it didn't work out for
them and so um that usually means that
they have to flip short in some way or
another again I'm using a Futures type
of explanation because that's more
accessible I'll get into the more
advanced option stuff later but um let's
say that there's a lot of these trap
Traders and then all of a sudden we have
a trajectory all the way down um to this
big node here at
4215 but hey that didn't happen right we
popped above eventually that
4235 and then what happened after that
well immediate squeeze up right
immediate squeeze up uh and so that was
a pretty beautiful trade like just to
see hey look there's a lot of um
essentially Longs or short puts building
up underneath here not to mention these
guys right which are trapped and so the
thing is if price stays above puts um as
like as the day is progressing
especially because we're only looking at
zero DTE in the options profile and
sorry that's something I should have
said earlier um then those puts start to
Decay right um and this is getting into
the less Futures and more options type
of perspective on this stuff those puts
are going to Decay and as they Decay um
it essentially is kind of like um people
getting like the market as a whole is
getting slightly more and more and more
long it's passively getting more long um
and so I don't know if you guys have
heard you know on Twitter people will
say or jeem carzon will say something
like hey time is not exactly charm
effects yeah time is not a bear's friend
um and we can see that on a like on a
zero DTE basis when people are in puts
and then all of a sudden towards the end
of the day the last couple hours they
have to start to get out and so if these
guys are trapped holding on to these
puts down
here and um yeah exactly they have to
cover and that squeezes us right back up
okay cool um so a really good example
actually of a trade from earlier today
where you could have been watching this
positioning and I mean I actually I was
I didn't do the best job of it but you
know I did what I could at the time um
and it took a while it took a while
right because they're they're fighting
over it but at the end of the day you
can see right like there's it's very
very hard for us to sell off so long as
we stay above
4230 um yeah no no worries orderflow
um all right so we've started to get
into a little bit of the um like more
option stuff uh let's actually hop over
to what's happening right now because um
that's kind of interesting so we just we
just kind of squeezed right so we saw
like um for those of you guys that are
watching es we were uh consolidating we
had a bit of a selloff down to
4268 um which incidentally is 4230
because the es premium or it's uh it's a
little 10 points higher it's right here
um uh 687 yeah because it's there's a 30
point premium so essentially we sold off
to down there um and then we popped
right back up and so essentially what
happened is like these long puts became
our next um our next supportive level
here uh and then in terms of projections
as to where we can go now things are
kind of messed up right like we could
see a full retracement today because
there's a ton of puts underneath us um
and then our next sort of big Target
would be these 4250 which are long calls
right and so this is something very
specific to SPX and I put it in the in
the practice document which is that
because SPX tends to be um short ball
and I'll get into that a little bit more
um in the in a little bit but these
short options levels um they tend to act
uh like accelerance actually right so to
the point where if we were to get above
you know these short calls we're
definitely going to this next level if
we get above these we're probably going
all the way up here um but the long
options levels they tend to stall us out
um and that has to do a little bit with
um with uh like the customer versus
dealer positioning stuff um but one
thing to think about a really intuitive
way to think about it is imagine that
you're holding on to these 4250 calls
long calls right and all of a sudden
price comes right up into them um at
that point you're at maximum gamma you
have maximum convexity on those options
um so it is the perfect time for you to
liquidate and if you're still bullish
roll those options up and when you
liquidate and a lot of those holders do
what happens effectively is you're
adding short Deltas to the market which
brings brings price back down and the
same applies for put levels right so
that's why these long options on SPX
they tend to stall us out and act more
like muggy or muddy territory um whereas
if we get Beyond or to sort of short
strike um it tends to actually
accelerate us
further I'm going to take up a second
here let me get back
live all right
great so that's why we're to my mind
right now right like that's why we're
kind of stalling here at these
4250 um it's because there's a lot of
people and you can literally see them
right now right like they're liquidating
they're getting out um not everybody but
a lot of them are getting out um so even
though we're consolidating above vwap on
ES um we're actually stalling out a
little bit here now my expectation would
be if we do get above this strike we
have a pretty clear path back up to 4265
which kind of Accords with the
principles that I was using before where
I'm saying hey like there's not a lot
over here um there's not a lot over here
to stop us all right I'm going to take a
second and go through there's a couple
questions that came
in um let's see oh I guess somebody
deleted one um for the record long
options mean long calls and long puts
correct yeah so um right like we want to
make
it we we tried the other way and it was
very counterintuitive to read so what
we're trying to do here right like if
something is to the right it means that
customers are long that option whether
it's a put or a call uh if that option
is to the left it means that customers
are short those options again whether
it's a put or a call um so right now you
know for those of you who are a little
bit more option oriented said um this is
actually you could characterize this
particular strike the 4250 as a
synthetic long here um and we do tend to
stall out around synthetic long so
they're short the 4250 puts and long the
4250 calls um and so that's kind of like
a long Futures position right there so
there's a lot of like as we come up into
it you know there's
um there's going to be a lot of
processing as people are trying to get
in or out of those positions and sort of
reconfigure
the other thing to note um and actually
maybe I'll get into into gex for this a
little
bit uh oh that's a good point let me
reload oh there we go
okay
okay yeah I'm I'm back live
here current strike at
4255 does that mean that there's no
intervention before
um actually I'm going to load history
again because I want to see what
happened here over the last couple
minutes before I answer
that hey Freddy um yeah so I'm going to
get into spy a little bit in a second
because it it actually gets pretty
interesting um because it does depend on
um like the ticker is is relevant here
so I'm for the purposes of this I'm just
really just covering
SPX okay yeah so nothing really changed
about that 4250 and then it looks like
these puts these short puts are
bailing uh these calls are actually
holding steady and then 4255 short calls
are also growing but these puts are
bailing um so this just looks like
consolidation to me like nothing
particularly conclusive at the
moment no no the chart Auto refreshes
the only reason that I I had a little
bit of bugginess there was because I
loaded the full history from the day and
I'm keeping it
loaded um so we're still working out a
couple Kinks with that that's all that
that
was
um
yeah all right
cool
so another another thing that I I want
to go into and point out here right um
aside from keeping in mind that there's
that that difference between long
options and short options is that our
proximity to a very large strike is
relevant so um so for instance like
let's go back in time and think about
these 4230s again um they were huge
right and then as price price starts to
move away from them people start to bail
out of those options because they're
actually taking profit right like that
trade has played out um in large
part but the other thing to not right
because this is volume it's not gex um
is that um the maximum juice that those
are providing for us in terms of pushing
price up right because remember what I
said about these being sort of offers to
buy the market down here or bids rather
sorry um is that as we move away from
that strike and this gets a little bit
into more of the option stuff uh the
power that those are providing Us in
terms of juice for upside uh is
diminishing right so in theory right if
you want to see us squeeze
then I mean this is not a terrible setup
because we have puts here here and all
the way down here but our juice sort of
reduced because we don't have as many
puts underneath us um and these are long
calls here so these holders could be
liquidating which is stalling us out um
if on the other hand we have um
regardless of whether they're short puts
or long puts underneath us and we're
hopping above um short call strikes um
those sort of just add to the fire right
like they add to the fire I mean they
they they give us more juice right and
so a lot of times when you see these
massive squeezes on SPX what's actually
happening and this will get to your
question Freddy um what's actually
happening is that we're squeezing
through short call
options um and what's like the reason
that that's happening and a lot of times
you actually won't see short call
holders on SPX liquidate um what'll
happen is they're probably hedging
either in the Futures Market or using
more sophisticated um means to hedge um
meaning that they're long elsewhere and
so you'll see us go through all these
short call options and just squeeze all
the way up the chain um and so long as
we don't have a massive strike above us
like this
4265 and rather we have what I call
clean laddering where we have you know a
short call strike short short call
strike sort of in a in a very nice nice
clean pattern we can just keep on going
um and that gives you pretty decent
confidence for
continuation all right let me um the
Dynamics that I clarified here um some
of them are um irrespective of the
ticker but
um the majority of them
um or sorry another another half or so
of them um do depend on what you're
trading specifically also give me a
second guys because I think having the
loaded history with the live stuff is is
making this a little
bit janky
[Music]
today this is why we do a soft launch
before we do a hard
launch
are you guys having um oh there we go
okay all right let's switch over to um
and this time I won't load history and
let's switch over to
spy so spy is actually a lot clearer
today you can see that it's short
options All Along The Chain right so um
according to what I was saying before
right if we're able to make it above 424
it's very likely that we're able to like
continue the squeeze until we start to
see a strike that builds up with short
call options to sort of cap us for the
day
right um the thing to keep in mind about
spy is that the players are slightly
different um right so there's more
retail trading SPY obviously because the
um the cost of the individual contracts
is lower and also what's really
interesting though is that there's a lot
of short options on spy right um and so
there is a lot of sort of institutional
trading of spy as well it's very very
liquid it's slightly less tax efficient
but um it's still a really really good
vehicle to trade um so Freddy you were
asking my experience has been that if we
were to hop over into the order flow tab
in terms of having a directional bias
spy is often a lot better um and I think
that's because there are more um there's
a difference between there there's more
long options on spy in general than SPX
um and that's also because in general
okay here we go we're squeezing above
that uh
424 okay so if that does happen then I'm
expecting some more upsite here just FYI
um um sorry what I was saying is that uh
in general when people are purchasing
options and mass especially on SPX also
on spy um it means that they're actually
more confident uh that there's more of a
directional bias there and the reason is
that if you're short options right you
can still be wrong somewhat wrong about
Direction uh and make money especially
if you're trading zero DTE off the fact
that um off of the charm um and
basically right like the the way that
volatility is going to get sucked out of
the marketplace into the end of the day
um but if you're long an option then
time is against you um and you have to
be right directionally so for instance
like a lot of times we'll see for
instance we'll be on SPX and I mean
today not so much right because there's
the only long options are really
relatively close to the money and the
short options um are sort of all across
the chain but a lot of times and I
pointed this out on the Twitter if you
see a really big um accumulation of uh
of long calls let's say come in over
here right uh off the open especially
like that gives me a very very strong
bias for the day because that means that
somebody's out there and they have a
massive amount of conviction it's not
entirely clear to me right because we
don't we're not monitoring every single
Marketplace whether those options are
there to hedge something my my intuition
is that they are right they're there to
hedge like an upside tail risk or
whatever but it doesn't really matter
because um the fact that somebody sees
that there's risk there and needs to get
long options um and I'm talking about
seeing like you know what is this uh
there's around 2300 like let's say that
there's like 4,000 of them um out of the
money up here like that is a pretty
pretty uh bullish sign similarly if you
see really like deep out- of the money
puts come in at the beginning of the day
in zero DTE right like long right that's
kind of a warning sign if you see them
come in short um that's completely
riskof it's saying hey somebody's like
super happy to offer up um all of this
volatility to players right all of this
downside convexity to people so um yeah
all right just a quick update here we
are actually finally pushing up as I
said right like this is is going to be a
muggy area we hop over into spy and we
see oh okay look at that we hopped over
424 looks like we're probably clear to
at least get up to
425 um I mean these short puts right
here are actually pretty a pretty nice
sign for that as well um so you know
that would be my
expectation more or less all right so um
I kind of started with the volume
profile type reading I've already sort
of moved my way a little bit into
thinking about um you know how
participants um who are actually trading
these options are thinking about um
about volatility and thinking about
time um but there's a lot more to say as
far as that's concerned
um and like part of that is you
know just uh give me a second
actually I'm going to answer a couple
questions because I'm feel like I've
talked myself out a little bit I just
got kind of excited about this stuff
because it's cuz it's fun it's like um
for the first time you get to see the
full uh or I mean that's what it felt
like to us like seeing the whole board
right um just to compare it to Classic
right like in classic we just have to
make these assumptions where we're like
okay you know this is gex by volume here
like this is how much we have at all
these different places um but we don't
know how much of that has been bought or
sold um and now all of a sudden you get
this sort of picture where it's very
very um there's a little more thinking
to do but also the landscape is so much
clearer um to me
anyway
um yeah anyway for me it would be
relatively bullish that we're holding
above these uh long calls right here um
on SPX and then you know obviously our
next node here is the 42 55s but there's
like a kind of a low volume area here so
if we pop this guy I'm expecting a nice
little trip up to
465 um but that might take a little bit
until later in the day because in order
for this to happen right um we need to
see like these puts need to Decay a
little bit more and you'll notice that
uh different periods of the day sort of
have different rates of uh decay in
terms of the in terms of the puts right
so that's why a lot of times you'll see
those squeezes come in at like 300 p.m
starting at 2:30 p.m. it's because all
of a sudden we start to see um a lot of
those options Decay people finally start
to realize in other words oh man you
know price isn't going to actually go
there I better get the hell out of these
um or I better hedge Myself by you know
buying something else and then we start
to see price come
up uh having a look at order flow yeah
yeah we can um I do want to stick around
here just in case people have more
questions because I know I have a
tendency to go through these things
pretty quickly so you know if you guys
have questions I'd really
encourage
um asking them
now is all the volume shown in state SL
next also present in state SL options
profile oh yeah I mean I I can go into
that
um yeah um so I'm not going to spend a
ton of time on the gex but yeah so full
right like next actually we'll go to
next first next is basically just taking
options profile and then grabbing all
the calls
uh and all the puts and then
representing the calls as uh positive
gamma and the puts as negative gamma uh
and there's a couple different reasons
that we did that I get into it a little
bit in the visualizations video but
basically we want to see where the
levels of Maximum convexity are right so
um instead of looking at options profile
right now for instance which is sort of
this like mess like it takes a little
bit more time to be able to read it
appropriately if you just hop into next
you can see what I'm saying it's really
clear already so we're above the 4250
like that is quite bullish for us um um
because it's acting as an accelerant but
then this guy here is putting uh
downwards pressure on price the the 4265
so we're kind of trapped between these
two levels here um and for instance oh
see that's not not particularly bullish
that this guy's been uh growing so it is
quite likely that we're going to come up
and tap um but for instance if we have
this the gamma here grow a
ton um and these guys down here diminish
it becomes less and less likely that
we're going to obtain that upside
right um and that sort of gets into
reading the gex charts a little bit more
but oh here we
go all right so we're starting to make
our
way
um so uh Freddy you're asking I said
that SX usually displays negative
convexity uh that's a good jump yeah so
so um when we're for those for for
um it might be unclear but uh another
word for these sold options right is
negative convexity meaning that um
people are short uh convex moves in the
market um and positive convexity is
everything on this side of the ladder
and that's going to set us up pretty
well for order flow so Freddy's asking
whether um the negative convexity that
is typically displayed on SPX is also
usually the case for spy um and this is
where things get a little more
interesting because it actually depends
a little bit on the sorry it actually
depends a little bit on the volatility
environment right
so uh what you'll often see and I mean
this is what we talk about this when
we're looking at for instance uh let's
see here net convexity
right um so and I'm on SPX yeah you can
see that at the beginning of the day
this is actually a really good example
let's just hone in on that for a
second we going to get it up here n
convexity great and I I'll go into what
this means in a little bit um but it
should be relatively clear um so at the
beginning of the day we were selling off
right and when we're selling off uh
people want to be long options uh
because volatility is
rising uh which means you want to be
long convexity you want to have um this
exposure to big moves in the market when
we're selling
off um and so you can really see that
right like we start the day and all of a
sudden boom people are buying options in
SPX buying more options in SPX and we
start selling off and we continue to
sell off and where does the bottom in
the market come in well all of a sudden
we move from an area being net positive
convexity um to all of a sudden there's
this dump right um it looks like people
just sold a ton of options another way
to think about that is hey a ton of
liquidity just came into the market a
ton of people are offering either to buy
or to sell and in general wherever
there's liquidity things are safe right
VA compresses and we go up um and so as
soon as you saw that come in we started
to move up
again um and then when this came in too
this was a big warning sign here it's
like oh we're coming up but it's not
done right we're not done in terms of
selling off and so we had this move we
tested and boom sell sold right off
again but when that did happen all of a
sudden convexity came down again meaning
people were selling options again
meaning people were providing liquidity
again once that happened all of a sudden
our base was Secure and price was able
to start to come up again um so that's
like let's say if I were to read net
convexity for the day on SPX um that's
kind of how I would go about it I should
mention also we are pushing up into that
node that I was talking about before on
spy but I don't really have time to hop
over into there right
now uh in any case to actually answer
your question Freddy and sorry it's
taken me so long um but SPX does usually
display a negative convexity because it
is the uh efficient value on selling
options is higher than buying options so
there's a lot of big players that are
really into selling options all the time
especially zero DTE on
SPX um and so yeah our default for SPX
is negative convexity right um also
convexity going like this this is
squeeze territory like this is um yeah
just
FYI um but yeah so so if we see
convexity be above zero net convexity be
above zero on SPX like that to me is a
pretty bearish sign like that does not
make me warm and fuzzy about the market
um let's switch over to to to spy since
you're asking about that
um and convexity on
spy oh boy so it looks like
spy knows what they're doing and they've
known what they're doing all day um so
this whole selloff you know was not a um
I guess spy Traders didn't think very
much of it um I will say right so I
would believe spy more in terms of a
directional bias I would believe spy
less in terms of a volatility bias uh
traders that trade volatility on SPX
tend to be smarter um traders that trade
Direction on spy um tend to be right
more of the time but you kind of just H
have to spend a little bit of time with
it um I think SPX is a lot clearer if
you see something really big come
through on SPX like you know what's
happening more or less um and uh a lot
of times actually the way that I put it
is when spy is wrong it is often very
very wrong um but if it's following
Trend as it is right now then we have a
really big boost on what we're doing
whereas SPX I would actually trust a
little bit more of the time um that
being said right like this is going to
depend a little bit on the volatility
regime it's going to depend a little bit
on who's trading SPX versus spy in terms
of you know institutional players versus
retail so you do I don't want to make
any sort of official pronouncements on
that you do have to spend a little bit
of time with it and sort of gauge what
volatility regime we're in um to figure
that out and maybe I'll have a little
more to say on that um in a bit let me
actually hop over to stay on
spy okay yeah so it looks like we're
playing with we're still playing with
that 424 and then back on
SPX all right yeah same deal same deal
as
before
it's really I mean you know these uh 42
65s are really sort of like being a buzz
kill right
now um and then on spy I wouldn't be
surprised yeah so this is not
particularly good
now because something similar can apply
you know in the same way as I was
talking about the puts where um right
like the puts decaying have a tendency
to push us up similarly right like the
short calls decay have a have a tendency
to put a cap on us so we had this really
interesting moment where had we got
about above 424 it's very likely and it
still counts for the rest of the day
it's only 146 right so if by 230 or so
we're able to get above 424 you know a
squeeze is very likely in the cards um
there's a lot I should also mention
right like there's a lot of choppiness
and craziness today and part of that is
because today is the Opex right and
we're looking when we're looking at
options profile when we're looking at
next in terms of gex we're looking at
zero DTE um and right now um as with any
Opex um people are trading and
reshuffling positions all the way across
uh the options chain into the future so
that can create a lot of choppiness and
unpredictability so it's kind of ironic
that we decided to you know or that I'm
doing this today but um you know it's a
Friday I'm done trading it made sense um
but yeah it's uh probably in Opex Friday
is one of the trickiest trickiest days
to trade this type of stuff it's not
that it doesn't work we had a really
good play earlier in the day but as
inventory starts to reshuffle you know
we're talking about longer dated stuff
people that are rolling their monthly
options out uh that can create some uh
how would I put it Jiggles in the
market all right actually for that
reason I do kind of want to hop over
into full and so I should mention that
right like full uh is actually running
our orderflow classification on uh 90
days worth of xes and then taking
essentially creating an options profile
full of all of that
volume um with 90 days worth of xeres
instead of just zero DTE and then taking
the gamma of the calls versus the puts
and putting it all into a single chart
um
so this is
like if instead of just looking at
what's going on today you want to look
at what's going on in terms of unmatched
inventory for the next 90 days or so you
can look here um which personally you
know I find a lot a lot easier to
watch all right so looks like we had
that test with whatever that was 424 on
spy and then on SPX it
was yeah 4255 is and now we're losing
that and like that's not particularly
bullish like when you see something like
this right usually and this is how now
moving away from um purely options
profile into gex a little bit but
usually if you want to see a squeeze you
want some sort of clean lading so we
would want some more calls to come in
over here and we want this guide to
diminish so that it doesn't act as a cap
because again whatever is all the way
above us is decaying pretty rapidly um
what's underneath us is actually
boosting us um in terms of gex
um and the reasons for that are sort of
more option but um that's kind of the
tldr yeah and you can see how they're
bailing out right bailing out of these
4250 is which is not particularly
bullish so you know if I had to sort of
revise my projection now that 424 failed
and now that um I forget exactly what
that was on SPX but it was also VW up on
ES um obviously I reserve the right to
change my mind but this is not looking
particularly bullish anymore
unfortunately or fortunately I guess it
depends what you're doing
all right let me
see
um okay I guess the last question was
about order flow and implementing it
um Can Circle back to
that but I do I do honestly spend most
of my time watching this
um
4250 all
right I I really wouldn't be surprised
to see us tap 4265 at some point
today
um all right let's hop over a little bit
into into orderflow here so short puts
short puts um remember I said the
proximity of those short puts or long
puts actually so long as we're above
them is quite relevant so because we're
so far away from all these big nodes
like they will have an outsized effect
like at the end of the day but for now
it's sort of uh medium
medium all right so I talked about
convexity for a little
bit um and convexity is like if you were
to imagine taking the gamma of uh all of
the long options versus the gamma of all
of the short options where the short
options have negative gamma and the long
options have positive gamma um right all
in terms of gamma exposure and then
putting it in a single metric that's
what net convexity does so it tells us
in terms of gamma are traders in SPX net
long um or
short uh options basically in terms of
they gamma
right um so for that reason right for
for instance like today even if we do
sell off like first of all
um despite the fact that the gex is not
like seems to give us that cap at
4265 um I'm not particularly bearish
like I wouldn't take a bearish trade
here because look at how many short
options there are like that doesn't
that's a lot of liquidity being provided
and so it's not likely that you're going
to get a massive break or anything like
that um barring any crazy Opex
phenomena um and then if we check spy I
think that we probably had a bit of a
jump there yeah so when we sold off here
we had a bit of a jump in net convexity
right because there's some more people
that got long options um and then but
and then uh it seems to be holding up
here if we see it come back down um I
think that'd be a little bit more
constructive net convexity is based on
only zero DTE um so in the future we are
probably going to be implementing more
expirations for all of these subplots um
including toggles to switch between you
know different ranges um because then
you know it can adapt a little bit
better to your trading time frame right
now gex spot as a whole is really more
so designed for uh intraday
trading um can I get do you guys have
any requests in terms of uh you know
other metrics to look at I I'll I'll
toggle down um and we can kind of jump
between
them
also hor do I feel like you noticed
something really cool
um the other day I forget exactly what
it was uh deck like order flow or the
aggregate aggregate
okay oh that's interesting on spy so it
looks like um
so actually I I'll get both of those on
there so that we can
uh let me put this guy on Dex orderflow
I'm going to get the filter low because
it's what we care about right now and
then I'll get this guy on
aggregate so um for Dex orderflow what
we're doing is um right every order that
comes in and let me hop back into
options profile here for a
second um okay I guess we'll stick to
spy so every order that comes in right
like let's say it's a short put well
then that's a bullish order so we're
going to take the Delta of that order
and the Delta of that order that came
through right multiplied by the number
of contracts is going to show up here
and it's going to show up as positive
because that those were bullish Deltas
that came in um on the other hand right
if you have short calls those will show
up as bearish Deltas if you have long
puts those will show up as bearish
Deltas but if you have long calls those
will show up as bullish Deltas so it's
kind of a way of keeping track um of big
trades that are coming through and it is
pretty cool for catching transitions so
for instance um I don't know if you guys
can tell but like let me see let me
bring the filter up a little
bit can just see that
guy so right here for instance right um
SPX came up we had a massive order that
came in uh bearish Delta order and then
it completely marked a big pivot and we
came right back down down right so it
can be useful for doing that type of
stuff right it's a way of um basically
taking an options order and then
characterizing it in terms of um sort of
its stock equivalent or what it would be
like if somebody just you know um went
short a ton of shares over there um and
then what we do is we take uh me get
this back to where it is right there's a
lot of activity going on here and so we
want to take all this order flow and
then aggregate it over the course of the
day and say okay you know have people
bought more or sold more using options
over the course of the day and you can
see as we were selling off on spy it
looks like there were a lot of
contrarian traders that just kept on
trying to buy and buy and buy and buy
and this is what I mean sometimes about
spy being a little bit wrong um because
a lot of times it's retail and so as
soon as they started to give up and get
out and sell that's when the market
actually stabilized and we started to
come back up and that's not super crazy
to see I bet let's take a look at the
same thing on SPS X actually that would
be
interesting oh looks like it's exactly
the same on SPX actually let me reload
just to make sure but
yeah oh no okay that makes a lot more
sense um and yeah there's a couple of
Kinks like that that we are still
working on but this is exactly what I'm
saying Freddy where for instance if you
look at aggregate decks on SPX
um it was coming down during the selloff
and then started to get bullish before
uh the index actually started to come
back up again um so SPX Traders were
really thinking ahead whereas spy
traders in terms of aggregate decks um
were very much behind the curve in zero
DTE and just trading reactively to the
market so a lot of times especially in a
higher volatility regime um I do prefer
to use spy as sort of an indicator to
fade because okay here's the other thing
to keep in mind right um when when we're
in you know zerp like zero interest rate
like markets just go up all the time uh
the degenerate retail traders that get
long spy calls all the time actually
tend to do pretty well um and so you're
not in a bad position if you follow what
they
do but as soon as volatility starts to
rise and the markets get a lot more
choppy and things get really crazy at
that point I think it's that the
professionals start to shine a little
bit more um and so in a higher
volatility environment I would really
lean towards trusting SP PX and using
spy as a uh as an indicator to fade
mainly
um okay is net connexity I'm I'm getting
through all these questions
um Freddy you asked if it's possible to
get history for multiple days uh right
now we don't have that um because it's
actually a massive amount of data uh
what does happen though is for instance
like if you want to review Friday or the
previous day um you can review it until
8:00 a.m. the next day um and
technically this is sort of a bug maybe
a feature but if you leave your um if
you leave your tab open and just keep
history loaded um you can keep multiple
days of History loaded on there until it
crashes your browser so uh you know have
fun trying that
out okay
um
oh okay so somebody asked you know that
I I tweeted a couple days ago about a
local top in Dex order flow which ended
up being the top for the day and if I
can talk about that tweet um so to be
honest um the way that that worked was I
was looking I'm pretty sure I was
looking at SPX because that's usually
what I look at and I just saw for
instance right like you guys can see
right there's like massive orders
sometimes that come in um and when they
do
um and and so I mean it was that plus a
little bit of context I mean it was
mostly just luck that that was the top
for the day right because just because a
really big order comes in that doesn't
mean that um it's going to determine the
rest of the day right like there's like
flow like conditions are always changing
like the way that we built this is so
that you guys can see stuff live and
adapt to the changing environment um so
no I mean that was I saw that that was a
really relevant order and so I marked it
and then it just ended up being the top
more or less for the day which was more
luck than not I will say though if you
did pull up Dex order flow for that day
um the other two sort of tests of that
same level also got really negative Dex
order flow so um you could experience a
little bit of reinforcement there
actually all right moving
on um can you filter Dex flow for any
DTE uh no not right now right now it's
just zero DTE again because this is
really just made for intraday stuff but
um that is that is in the plan it
probably won't be any specific DTE it's
probably going to be um either zero or
then a week or uh like a month or
something like that um so we'll probably
choose like three main ranges and
actually that's something I'm working on
figuring out exactly what I think the
best ranges the most actionable ranges
are um but yeah that that should get
built in eventually all right so hor dog
appr propo of all these questions
regarding we're going to be doing uh
hard dog's asking if we're going to do a
road map page and yeah so right now
obviously because this is a pretty big
release we've been really busy with
um yeah exactly I think that's probably
what I'm going to do end of week end of
month sorry um we've obviously been
super busy with this release uh there's
been a lot that's been going into it
obviously you guys have noticed you know
there there always a couple bugs along
the way uh overall things have gone
really really well super happy with it
um but the first thing that we're going
to do uh once we get through hard launch
which is on October
30th um is that we're going to get
together and we got a ton of feature
requests from beta testers from um from
you guys as well and we're going to sit
down basically map out all of those
feature requests um prioritize them and
then just hack them off one by one and
as part of that uh we're going to
release our road map as well so that's
going to be like okay by this you know
by Q whatever Q2 we expect these
features but Q3 we expect those all that
stuff so that you know if you sub
especially to the upper packages you can
know what to expect in terms of upgrades
uh in the future um because right this
is a I want to mention this like in
terms of what we have on the back end
right um as you guys can probably sort
of
see this is sort of just the surface
because um on the back end we're running
orderflow classification on you know uh
we can run it on an arbitrary number of
xeres I mean we're doing 90 days right
now um but if you look at options
profile you can only see Zer DTE in
addition we have vaa we have charm we
have uh we even have color like we have
uh SEC we have first order second order
third order Greeks for everything every
order that comes through all the time
that's all already built um the question
is just how do we want to present the
data um and um how do we make it um you
know as legible and actionable as
possible right so we want to we want to
make sure that we're very deliberate
about number one the tickers that we
include I've gone over this many times
but the thing is right like if we put on
I don't know um some like offshore oil
stock that
gets you know uh a thousand um options
worth of volume um every week or
something like that it's not going to be
particularly useful on this platform
right um we want to make sure that we're
doing things with really high options
volume things that um
that for which we think this can be
useful and things that people are
actually trading right um and then also
the visualization like we're you know I
think Jasper's very very careful about
about that and making sure that
everything stays as clean as possible
because the idea here is not to provide
a platform where you know you go there
and you do your research on tons of
xeres and tons of tickers and all that
stuff like this is something this is a
trading tool right you need to be able
to look at it get a quick read of what's
going on and be able to act on that
information like that's the the mission
statement I
guess okay Freddy you trade es and use
gamma for your map
um use the options ladder from thinker
swim the data we guys get is from Freddy
can you specify that a little bit more
I'm not really sure what you mean by
from the whole
Market where do we get the data from um
so our data is not from thinker swim we
have um uh
we have a provider
uh so there's I don't know if I want to
disclose our specific provider but we we
it's it's basically an API
uh uh websocket right so we're getting
all the data like every single
millisecond um sort of like it's like a
brutal fire hose worth of data um and so
there's provider right if you think
about your broker right um
your broker is actually getting data
from a provider like either sibo or I
mean Spider Rock is another relatively
famous one uh there's DX feed um they're
they're all these like big data
providers and so um and they sort of
sell things uh in bulk right um and uh
so so right we have we have a contract
with that we get everything sort of raw
from them and then we process it we
actually calculate all of our Greeks uh
in house because I don't particularly
like love the way that they do their um
that most of these providers do their
volatility implied VA calculations um if
you really want to get into the weeds
but um yeah um
it's that that that part is actually
pretty
fun so not super surprising that we've
been chopping around here right like if
you look at this from sort of that
volume profile perspective that I was
talking talking about we have that
synthetic long that's been hanging out
here it's doing literally nothing um we
had you know uh I guess more short puts
are coming in here um some of these long
puts are bailing uh these short calls
seem to be bailing as we're selling off
here but in general right we're just
kind of stuck in the muck here um and
and and more specifically right like we
have excuse me we have these like really
big short puts here that we talked about
earlier really like big strike along uh
sorry short calls up here and they're
just pinning us and that's usually the
effect that I see when we see and that's
why
um uh you know I had that tweet the
other day where I was like okay you know
it seems like we're walled in between
these two really big levels off the open
um and then of course on that day right
we break through um the the lower wall
um but in generally when you see
something like this it's really telling
you okay here's our range like we're
we're in sort of a reversionary
environment um if we were to break break
Beyond uh 4230 that would be an epic
selloff um similarly if miraculously we
get above 4265 you know we're getting a
squeeze for the
ages uh okay data dark pool data um no
we don't have dark pool data um this is
all like the entire platform is options
analytics right so we're not looking at
transactions
in
uh like stock transactions or dark dark
pools or anything like
that neither are we planning on doing
that just to remind everybody I'm still
on the camp of just we we get we're just
muddling around here uh especially
because of this you know mess of a
strike that's just capping us here and
then um most likely as these puts start
to Decay we do end up towards the end of
the day probably after 2:30 making our
way up and tapping it at some point
um and the basis for that is
just um the fact that um we're not
selling off um and if we're not selling
off then there's a lot of like decay in
the end at towards the end of the day
typically takes more juice out of the
puts than it does out of the calls um
and then on top of that just this is a
really big liquidity level
that being said unless we get you know
more uh more calls or more short puts
building up underneath us it's going to
get hard it's going to be hard for us to
get up there sort of organically so to
speak yeah you see what I mean where
it's like okay so there's these long
calls right here right 4250 and then as
we're hovering around that level they've
just been bailing out of them because
you know they're just they're just not
really worth holding on to as we get
into the end of the day um and if you
did really want to get long you'd get
into these or you'd get into those but
it doesn't seem like there's a lot of
participation
there and again you know this is a very
different Dynamic from earlier in the
day when we were just selling off and
coming into this 4230 and you could see
that they were adding short puts this is
I mean we kind of purposefully did this
in the middle of the day because it's
hard to do these like more educational
live streams when there's a lot of stuff
going on like I remember the last one we
tried to do during an fomc and it was
just kind of nutty um I'm also probably
not experienced enough with the live
streaming to to to do like when I'm
really thinking about the markets it can
be a little a little tricky obviously
because this is um intense stuff
but but yeah
yeah oh look at
that the game on this guy is diminishing
as we sell off a little
bit so that would make a lot of sense
for
instance if we're able to actually come
back down here maybe touch 45 maybe
touch 40 and then slowly make our way
back up towards the end of the
day
again not necessarily encouraging this
type of speculation just sort of like
teaching moment type of thing in fact
like I wouldn't really put any trades on
around here especially not on an Opex
Friday not a good
idea thanks Mel I appreciate it I'm kind
of I was kind of nervous that you were
in here to be honest because uh you're
the much more experienced uh live
streamer so I I very much appreciate
that
okay awesome awesome yeah and hopefully
so I'm I'm recording all this so this
will turn into a video and then
hopefully we can do you know maybe like
one a week or something like that I
don't know if that's too ambitious but
then uh over time you know give people a
good uh set of
um um a good a good set of resources
right to to be able to to sift through
because really there is no substitute
for screen
time uh slot gamma yeah so offering the
difference between es and SPX is
definitely one of the features that I
want to implement I think that that'd be
I mean honestly that'd be super helpful
for me because I mostly trade
ES
all right so they were getting out of
these calls we broke down 43 looking
at still kind of Mucky but there's not a
ton I mean there not a ton to save us
from getting to 35 before we do
anything although we are at vac um like
month B on ES so
that's that's something I guess
but I would really wait
until again none of this is financial
advice when I'm talking about you know
trading or recommendations or whatever
I'm talking about that for the purposes
of um conveying how I'm perceiving the
options profile um mainly for
educational purposes all right but that
being said um what I would what I would
contemplate here is if we are able to
get for instance down to uh 4235
something like that I might think
about getting long and tend of day
there also Freddy um thanks for making
all those uh I I don't know if it's you
or your your co uh cooworker
collaborator um for making all those
videos I also wanted to say because we
haven't really gotten a chance to uh
you know to uh get to know each other
but
[Music]
um
views
can I explain the order flow for today
um sorry who was that
again
um what do you mean by explain the order
flow for
today uh like is there a particular
aspect a particular indicator that
you're interested in a particular time
period okay looks like we are looking to
tap uh 35
soon
kind of want to hop back into spy and
see what's going on here oh man this is
actually so much clearer than SPX right
now like just to see how it's like okay
we had all these short calls up here we
had a moment where we could have broken
above 424 and gotten our squeeze but
then it didn't work and so now all of a
sudden we're in this pocket down here
where you know there's just nothing and
all these calls above us are decaying
pushing us back down and so you know our
next destination looks like lows of the
day 422 something like that and I
actually to be honest I had a really
hard time believing it like let's go
back to orderflow because something
really cool was happening here um so
right spy order flow we were saying you
know was getting more bearish at the end
of the day um and I was like well you
know spy order flow really volatile you
can kind of fade it a little bit um
looks like they've been doing okay but
SPX was really is really what I'm
thinking about right now um and look at
this so like we were coming up right
into the like in over the last while
we're coming up here and SPX orderflow
they're just shorting shorting shorting
shorting and now we're finally getting
the sell off and I really you know I was
kind of biased a little bit where I was
thinking H like yeah we could break
Above This level if we break Above This
level we have a lot of upside left in us
and yet aggregate decks on SPX was just
saying nope no way and this guy right
here 1 p.m. like literally on the dot
massive order like that's the right here
like wow um and you can see how they
basically just like we came up and they
just said
nope not anymore um so this is one case
in which you know aggregate
decks on SPX is just doing such a great
job you're not seeing much long SL
shortfall uh everything falls under the
category of long and short
ball 1 p.m. decks could have been
misleading 1 pm decks on which
ticker SPX
okay
um I mean yeah sure it can be misleading
right like that's like if if a big order
comes in right like you don't know when
that person is going to exit that order
like that's why you you have to use
levels and risk management and those
types of things if you're trading
something like this right just because
you see a really big order came through
doesn't mean that um that's going to
determine the trend for the rest of the
day right it depends that's why we have
the uh State that's why we have the
ladder um so you can see levels and you
can see them growing and diminishing in
real
time uh so if you have access I mean I'd
encourage you to you know load history
and go back and look at what you know
what positioning looked like around 1
p.m. uh and then you can see how SPX
responded to that
but um incidentally right I my claim I
suppose was that I wanted to see
something us get around uh two I think I
said 35 actually uh and then around 2:30
p.m. you know then then I had sort of
more of a bullish outlook for the rest
of the day and I think that's still
holding steady like this was a nice
little
sell a nice little sell
here
no aggregate deck is just zero DTE right
now uh eventually we're looking to
implement more uh more
DTE but yeah so in in terms of like how
I would view positioning right now to
answer sorry I don't know why it's like
blocking out your uh your name I think
your SPX something the guy with the the
gray the gray hair um looks like uh I
don't know what is that um one of the
one of those Marvel characters or
something one of the um Avengers I I
don't know anyway um jpow there we go
jpow that's you are I feel like I see
you around but um we've never like
interacted before too much um so so yeah
my take right uh is pretty simple based
on like what we have right here which is
we have these boundary conditions right
4265 and then these 4230s and so we're
trading inside this range right within
this range it's likely to be pretty
Mucky um but I do have a little bit of a
bearish bias until we hit around 230 and
some of the Decay starts to hit these
puts more strongly uh if we do fall
under these 4240s I'm expecting 4235 at
that point I would look to see if the
4230s down here start to add the short
puts if they do then it's a pretty
decent long
entry if they don't then we're probably
going
there um and uh yeah let me think if I
have any other takes no that's that's
mostly it for right now I mean if you
were to look at at full here right and
this is something that I could have you
know I I was talking about a little bit
earlier which is look at how these this
call Gam up here is decaying right part
of that's that price is coming down but
part of that's that people are also
bailing out and taking profit on those
short calls um and so if we come right
into negative gex all of a sudden we
have a different picture where we're
looking at okay let's see if we can hit
one of these really major levels whether
it's 35 or 30 and what sort of a
reversion we get off of there because
that could actually be quite
powerful but it's going to require us to
get further into the end of the day so
essentially what we want to do is we
want price to kind of come down see if
people get suckered into buying a lot of
puts and then if we get a bounce off one
of these levels that can lead to one of
those feedback loops that could take us
a lot higher especially if there isn't
as much juice in these 42 65s anymore
that are kind of putting a cap on us
again we want to see in terms of gex we
want to see kind of a clean laddering
where because these can act as
accelerants right if we get above uh the
4245 right it's like boom we're above
there it can push us up to the next one
that can push us up to the next one and
so forth but in order for that to happen
the acceleration that each of them
provide have to be more or less
equivalent because when we're over here
these guys are actually pushing down on
us the with the 42 55s are actually
pushing down like let's say we're
between these two strikes then the 45s
are going to push us up and 55s are
going to be pushing us down so if we can
get a clean lading effect it means that
each time we get we get past go so to
speak right we get past each little
patch I I actually kind of think about
them like those like little accelerators
in Mario Kart like if you guys have ever
played that where it's like if you go
over that little patch of terrain or
whatever it like shoots you forward
faster um but uh the problem is this guy
being too big puts downward pressure on
us so it becomes a lot harder to
accelerate up all right um I'm going to
take a bathroom break I'll be back in a
little
bit um yeah and we'll see if we can get
that uh squeeze into
close
oh
for
e
all right can you guys hear
me okay
great so looks like we are hitting
coming down into that 35 level that I
was looking for a little while back
see how the profile is
changed
okay looks like short puts at the 30 are
growing they think that that's safe and
then looks like uh basically long puts
have grown as well and short calls have
two um what's interesting though I mean
these puts over here the
4250 have been those short puts have
been coming out okay I guess that's all
pretty consistent um this is interesting
though these guys are
bailing some of these guys are scared
too yeah nothing particularly bullish
right now unfortunately I mean I say
unfortunately the reason I say that is
because I only really like to trade from
the long side um so I just I won't short
the market um but that's just a you know
a psychological personal thing right
doesn't it's not a recommendation for
anybody
I'm I'm curious have you guys been able
to uh get on to the free
trial so you can have this on your own
computer okay great Peter I'm glad to
hear
that awesome also right like we
recognize that you know order flow is
quite pricey that is really for um very
right like it's it's for a specialized
crowd um to some extent
um yeah there JP yeah there are plans to
add van and charm actually oh look are
we bouncing off 45 or oh no 40 we got
all the way down to 40 Okay
cool so pgo are you already
subscribed because if you're if you're
already oh okay well then just go on the
website go on the uh pricing page on the
website uh JP jpow we haven't even
started building it so um I mean it's
all built on the back end we haven't
started building it on the um on the
front end yet so we don't know where
it's going to go in terms of pricing
yet uh combo position at
4215 both calls inputs okay let's see
Mel
4215 oh sure yeah um so it looks like
right like wow we really something off a
bit
here
um so if
they're I mean to be honest like these
calls are not super relevant to me
because they're so small um but when you
do see a strike like this which is long
calls and long puts that's actually a
really good point Mel so um it means
that generally uh we're expecting
volatility expansion into this node
similarly right like imagine this were
reversed let me see if I can find a
strike like that um actually not so much
today but imagine it we're flipped right
and we have short call and a big short
put at the same strike um what that
means effectively is that
um like the participants are expecting
price to go there right um if you have a
long um long put and a long call at the
same strike what that means is anywhere
but here it means they're expecting an
expansion of volatility away from that
zone so basically the idea would be um
with this position like imagine that the
put and the call were the same um
magnitude let's
say then if price stays above then it's
going to shoot up like crazy and if
price breaks below then it's going to
sell off like crazy so it's a it's
basically a long straddle right um
whereas um if you have both short in One
Direction then it's going to be a short
straddle and so they're expecting price
to go there and volatility to compress
and if effectively what we do see a lot
of the time is if we get big positions
like that um price does tend to just
hover around there and just you know
chop around which is kind of cool but
yeah in this particular case yeah yeah
exactly totally yeah if you have um
short call short put you should expect
pinning around there
um yeah so if uh s that's a really good
question and we are going to incorporate
more vol ility stuff into here but yeah
if volatility comes down which I am
expecting until the end of the day I
would expect us to uh price to go up
absolutely it just hasn't been coming
down very much
yet because I mean look at all these
puts that are underneath us and this
4265 is not as relevant as it used to be
since we're so far away from it so I
wouldn't be surprised if we can get you
know 10 points to the upside 15 maybe
um yeah so the that's one of my main
projects once this is over is actually
incorporating uh live versions of skew
charts into here so you'll be able to
see it at the same
time uh so there's current c l no way of
um seeing implied the status of implied
volatility on the platform itself um you
can look at your options chain for that
where you can look at something like Zer
tsx.com they do a pretty decent job
although there's a around a 60-sec delay
on that site last time I
checked
so yeah this is looking pretty positive
actually now to be
honest yeah Barry that's a really good
question um a lot a lot right so uh
that's something I mentioned earlier in
the Stream which is that okay here we're
sorry just to interrupt myself we're
taking off from 40 from um 35 if we can
get above these two put strikes here
we're looking at some upside here like
actually which would be really nice you
know yeah so put selling right here um
but the thing is if we're above all
these puts it doesn't really matter
whether they're sold or bot just the
point is that we're above them they're
decaying and we're very likely to be
able to uh move upwards a little bit
which is why if you look at you know
full and next we actually take all the
puts and we group them all together
irrespective of whether they're bought
or sold because the only thing we care
about is that those positions exist
right um in terms of uh the influence
they're going to have on the market uh
Barry back to the Opex thing okay so I
was a little bit off I said what did I
say I think I said 45 for
my no did I say 45 I don't remember it
was a while back but um anyway we are
seeing that upside I did say 230 so that
was pretty that was pretty close not
that you know again um making
projections and trading are not the same
thing and uh just cuz you can make good
projections doesn't mean that you can
trade well and you can trade well
without making any good projections just
FYI so this is you know just a um how
would I put it a little sport here what
I'm
playing
um yeah SE the whole point of this is
that uh bars to the left are sold and
bars to the right are bought so these
puts are sold these puts are sold these
puts are sold these puts are bought
that's like the whole point of the
options
profile yeah and I mean I assume
probably from spending enough time in
bear trap you probably have a pretty
good idea of all the cool stuff that you
can do with that
information um and if you want to really
get confused about it ask o and he'll
give you a wonderful
explanation which is extremely
actionable but also terribly
confusing that's what that's what that's
what you get when you talk to the ball
guys you know like they they just um
which which I'm one of by the way I had
to sort of censor myself to um try to
explain this in the most intuitive
manner possible today because
[Music]
um all right
so let's look at this look at it's very
interesting they're getting out of the
4255 that's like a big reduction in
exposure right there um and then it
looks like these long puts are also
bailing so I I wouldn't be surprised if
we actually you know this is like a
pretty decent development here although
these long puts are adding here so I I
it's still a little mixed it's still a
little
mix
Allison yeah that's right uh bars to the
left are sold and bars to the right are
bought and this is from the customer's
perspective right not the dealer
perspective this is what other like
let's say that you're trading options
you want to see where everybody else is
this is what you look
at
also just looking at yes right now
footprint looks like there's not a ton
of liquidity right now I don't really
know what's going on
but it's kind of No Man's Land out
there yeah classic X is still naive yeah
that's the that's the point of the sort
of the upgraded platform I
[Music]
guess
oh I haven't been paying attention to
the news
Peter uh Al kind of try to stay I mean
for the purposes of you
know um just kind of going to keep to
looking at the price action looking at
the positioning and and working off that
especially for the purposes of any sort
of
uh company stuff I
guess my podcast on the other hand there
I can talk about whatever I
want I'm glad Peter yeah and like please
feel free to ask more questions I need
more uh so that not to generate content
sweet generous right just need a little
more
um yeah I'll just I'll probably stick
around till close uh I do the the bear
trap podcast on YouTube with um with a
buddy of mine from the bear trap
Discord um I mean lately he's been kind
of busy he's got you know kids in a job
and a lot of stuff to deal with so I've
been doing a little more of my own
things I haven't posted in a little
while though but I'll probably be doing
more more stuff soon since we've
launched
already
um
let me check the gex andex order for one
second so this is a pretty decent
inflection point uming at like 35
there so we We There is a bug right now
where um if you load up like when you
first load the orderflow pages there's
like a big bar that pops up which is
just like a like a JavaScript issue that
we're going to get rid of um but uh once
you've loaded the page whatever you see
there is what's in our database so
that's
accurate
so okay um no no no that's fine that
that that that um that's possible thanks
for letting me know yeah I'll um I'll
I'll look into
it there's always like uh there are
always little things like that that crop
up you know anything like
this all right looks like we actually
tapped 35 which is great you
know that's a big one
let me see what I'm looking at
here okay so these guys shorts are
holding strong these guys also kind of
expanded and then these guys are bailing
so
I'm you know tentatively a little
constructive here on price
actually
then we have okay
so yeah if we can just get up to 40
again then we should be good to go for a
bit but this is again the fight right
between those two long strikes they make
stuff pretty Mucky it's kind of
annoying
okay here we go starting to move a
little bit it's getting oh wow look at
that some long foots came in down
there these guys are bailing okay
beautiful is it 244 all
right and we're kind of clear here
actually hard to not be
constructive probably looking at if we
pop that guy that's going to muddle us
but then
we're wouldn't be surprised with
C55 all right we're on the
way ah 40 stalling
us
okay this is actually kind of
fun um okay um these guys are getting
out of the way which is great and then
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
up to the synthetic at 50 so I feel like
that would be a pretty decent Target if
you were here which translated for ES
premium uh 50 is going to be oh wow
really I can't be
right sorry I have a hard time sometimes
doing math in my head when I'm
like 50 yeah that's pretty far actually
it's like another 10 points up from
where we are right now so it's like 75
yeah thanks Peter you're right there we
go I should do these more often so
people can do math for
me uh good question Allison the DTE on
options profile is always zero like
these are prod um primarily intraday
tools uh it will Branch out down the
line but for now that's what they
are all right still working with 40 over
here but look at them bailing right like
they're getting the hell out of there
although I don't like how these guys at
underneath are
growing so it's not the you know it's
not the fuzziest feeling
here yeah no worries ellon
um okay looks like they lost
40 just consolidating
here
that was so interesting right so like we
got a really big response off of uh
35 brought us up to the next long strike
they're getting the hell out
but um we obviously stalled out a little
bit there so you can see that a lot of
times our consolidations on ES or
whatever they they happen in these like
fiveo ranges between like big strikes
oftentimes big long strikes on
SPX
h
I may have taken a slight little scalp
over there off of uh what was that off
35 it's kind of
nice I'm still constructed by the way on
on price it's just like do I really want
to have to deal with the emotional mess
of just waiting through this range it's
just
annoying it's not worth not worth the
emotional expenditure feel like that's
something that isn't talked about enough
I mean obviously there's a lot of
trading literature about you know um
sort of the emotional side of trading
like the mental game all that stuff but
something that like a concept that I
found really useful is just mental
capital or even emotional Capital which
is whenever you're in a trade whether
you realize it or not you are
sacrificing you're like you're raising
your overall anxiety and so you're
worsening Your Capacity to make
decisions and so time in
trade um is dangerous in a way right the
more time you spend in trades uh the
more difficult it is for your system
unless you're some type of you know
super demon like uh shout out to Clark I
don't know if he's in here but um yeah
that can make it you know that's a
that's a really relevant metric all
right so now we break
40 uh I'm looking for 50 if we break
40 yes I mean slot gamma so both um
right like convexity aggregated Deltas
all that stuff the those tilt indicators
um are largely uh they're in the
orderflow tab which I'm not going over
too much in detail today but but yeah
that's the idea with all of
those
it does SO trading does involve an
adrenaline kick and adrenaline kicks are
really useful really useful sorry for
flight and fight or flight
situations and really really awful for
situations that are not like that which
trading is
not so it's this sort of uh very
annoying thing where just engaging in
this activity is going to kick
off all sorts of mental processes that
um are going to make you worse at it so
you know I'm sure everybody in here
already knows that but it's it's just
worth thinking about every once in a
while I I do want to hop in overflow
take a look at some stuff
here okay yeah looks like SPX Traders
are still mostly bearish some some
bullish order Flow came in
there let's take a look at oh boy that
makes sense so that's all juice that we
can squeeze into EOD actually
actually
technically and convexity is rising
which is not
great see if we got any big orders here
okay so some bullish order flow bearish
order flow nothing
big let's hop in
spy
okay so spy is a little more
constructive index
terms which I don't think means very
much how do you tell order flow bullish
or bearish um okay so if somebody buys a
call that's bullish order flow if
somebody sells a call that's bearish
order flow if somebody buys a put that's
bearish order flow and if somebody buys
uh I say sell put sell a is bullish buy
it put is bearish so it's basically the
directional uh bias and Delta terms
behind uh behind each trade that we are
classifying that is how it is defined at
this
screen so bullish flow are those
categories that I just mentioned and
bearish flow are the other categories I
just
mentioned
no oh oh I understand your question now
okay yeah so bullish flow means it's
positive here like look at this axis
bearish flow means it's
negative uh apple and state tab yeah I
can hop over there one second I wan to I
just want to you know refresh myself a
little bit on I want to get updated on
what's been changing over here okay so
they're getting out of these that's good
they've been getting out of those more
short puts holding strong increased
short puts at 4225
okay the read is still kind of intact
unless something big changes we could
get some crazy orders at 3M right
remember everybody like this is Opex day
so you know who
knows um okay apple and state tab
selling
175 Apple
State uh yeah yeah I mean that's the
right way to read it such they are
selling the hell out of that 175 good
call
um yeah something I've been looking at a
lot lately actually is comparing
um you know um long options versus short
options in all the different tickers
like these big tickers Tesla Microsoft
Amazon Nvidia versus Spire SPX uh
they're selling puts in apple selling
180s and selling
175s which is kind of odd I mean I guess
you know there's bullish expectations
for Apple I mean that's a good call such
like I don't know that's kind of insane
to be honest like I don't know what
they're expecting
here um unless they're actually just
trying to buy Apple stock by the end of
the day like that would make sense right
if they're actually trying to get
exercise
here or they think we're going to
squeeze I mean if we squeeze above 175
like that's going
to that'll work out it's totally
[Music]
possible all right Power Hour
and I do expect that we're going to get
some
uh we've put in a higher low more or
less and we are above most of the
relevant foot strikes so it's pretty
hard to be bearish
here again barring you
know Opex
messes okay here we go we got that pump
beautiful all right we should make our
way back up to vwap at around 50 I
think or vac actually that what's 50
it's uh it's like what did we say Peter
we said like 75 or something oh that
would be quite a journey actually it's
possible
though no so everything is classified
everything
um oh awesome Mike I'm glad that helped
again not Financial advice but you know
we can help people make money
that's what we want to do so yeah every
single trade is classified um the uh how
would I explain
this
uh my confidence is very very high so
there's um we're not necessarily trying
to be precise right um or sorry we're
not necessarily trying to be accurate in
the sense that like um if a particular
strike
contains um and this just has to do with
how the algorithm Works uh we're not
necessarily trying to be accurate
meaning that um you know if I say that
this specific strike where like has uh
1,300 or whatever it might not be
exactly 1,300 right but what is super
super uh accurate is the relationship of
all these strikes to each
other um so and that's what's important
for reading this right so you know I'm
not not going to promise you that this
is exactly the number of you know 42 50s
calls that have been bought today but I
can um say with very high degree of
confidence that the relationship between
uh the magnitude of this strike and this
strike is accurate similarly for all all
of
them and so in that sense everything
gets classified uh everything gets put
through the
system yeah no worries it turns out that
when you make sacrifices it's like
everybody ends up being really really
focused on
um how would I put it
like those sorts of individual
factoids um and so I feel like there is
um a lack of understanding that and here
I'm talking about you know uh other
order flow classification systems out
there there's a lack of understanding
that what really matters is the big
picture what really matters is the
relationship between you know the
different tickers the relationships
between the different strikes the
relationships between the Greeks all of
that
stuff the number on the first grid line
um do you mean the the white one here
Allison like this white 4238
thing oh that's spot price so that's the
current price of
SPX the
vertical you mean this one minus
4,000
oh okay the vertical outside the spot
price well yeah these are just it's
classified volume right so like I can
you know eyeball it and be like okay you
know these 42 65s are around you know
there's about 4,000 of those that are
short
I actually have a I have a poll question
um so one of the things that bugs me is
that you guys see you know I'm playing
around with this cursor it's like pretty
responsive it's nice but the corners on
this guy are rounded right but the
corners on the cursor like on 4277 right
now there are that little block they're
not round it it's 90°
angles uh does that drive other people
crazy or is that just
me um because if people are fine with
that then I won't bug Jasper about it
but
like it's me okay all
right I mean that's good let's work for
Jasper you
know yeah exactly Mel I just want to I
want support I want to be able support
for fixing this bug like if everybody
gets behind me it's like those 90°
Corners are so bad it needs to get fixed
you
know all right uh little F uh what's it
called um Public Announcement here above
40 uh things are looking
good State SPX be applied to SC um no
not right now Simon uh that is
definitely
on the agenda as well because that's the
thing right like right now you sign up
for gex spot any tier and you can have
the classic uh levels on S chart which
is great and you know those levels are
still the big levels are still pretty
similar um oh here we go squeeze
time
hopefully options on Futures in the
pipeline uh yeah uh uh well yes and no
right I would say yes contingent upon
options on Futures volumes right because
what we're trying to do here is display
levels that um are relevant for intraday
price action and last time I checked um
volume and options on Futures was
relatively low meaning that the effect
that those are going to have in terms of
hedging Dynamics and all that is not
going to be really high uh so it's like
doesn't really make a ton of sense to do
um but
um but I'm going to look into that and
if if it if it hits a particular
threshold right where we're looking at
like pretty high volumes then then yeah
100% uh slot gamma can you specify what
you mean the Deltas of the individual
strikes Oh you mean decks don't you kind
of like the deck charts in um in bear
[Music]
trap
oh here we
go uh yeah slot GMA but like what do you
mean in terms of it being displayed you
also mean like basically um a price
ladder like we have right now except
that instead of having classified volume
it's it's Delta weighted classified
volume something like that like what
type of uh UI are you envisioning here
uh Allison so yeah I talked about that a
little bit more earlier in the Stream I
think before you showed up um also this
whole stream is going to be put on
YouTube so I'm recording it but uh tldr
right now um we are above all the major
put strikes for the day um and those are
going to be decaying uh as time on the
day runs out right so we have 60 minutes
left these are all zero DT options um
those are all people who are short um
more or less right there's somebody
who's short on either end of those and
um and those options are decaying um
which is meaning that
um basically the reality here is either
customers or dealers are able to buy
back Deltas into EOD uh and so that that
it makes it very likely that we're going
to get pushed
up
again I I wouldn't really trade this
price action guys like unless you're a
future scalper like I tend to do
sometimes because this is a mess it's a
complete
mess as Opex usually
is slot gamma so
I
mean uh options tra in general like when
you're trading an option you're never
trading the underlying Price Right like
there's a price for that option and like
if you're a very Advanced option Trader
then you're actually trading the uh
volatility uh right you're looking at
options in terms of vs um and if you're
very Advanced then you're actually just
trading straddles right you're like long
one straddle short another straddle um
all the way along the chain so um a cure
reference to have it look at it
separately or otherwise
um I feel like I need a little more
information to understand what you're
talking
about Good Question Barry let's see
all right so we're at oh wow yeah this
is a very supportive structure you guys
see what I was talking about earlier I
was like well you know these guys up
here if they fade away and we get a ton
of juice in the puts down here all of a
sudden that opens up the field to the
upside the 4250 is are completely gone
meaning that if we're able to get up
above 45 like we are all of a sudden Off
to the
Races
this still isn't my favorite structure
right like I don't like that these 65s
are bigger than everything else that's
kind of
annoying um but if they were to shrink
just a little bit more and these guys
were to grow just a little bit more we'd
be in in business and it is really nice
how like look at how big all of these
guys underneath us are so that's how
much it's you can think about it as this
is how much juice there is to Decay
underneath us the downside is if we
break underneath 40 the whole narrative
shifts right then all of a sudden we're
looking at a 30 close um which would
it's not my
favorite let's check out full to see if
we have a okay full looks even better
actually I would say this looks even
more
constructive
so that may be the case right it may be
the case that everybody got out of their
long 4250 uh zero DTE calls in fact I
think that that is
true they are getting out yeah
um but that's not necessarily a bad
thing
um right like I actually want more of
these call strikes to shrink a little
bit um so that we can kind of clear the
way to the upside so I just want puts
underneath us decaying and then call
strike's not really there stop us and
then we can just rock it um again not
super likely today because it's Opex and
all that stuff but I'm just talking
about the theory of all this although I
am still constructive on
price yeah this is a pretty decent
picture not ideal but pretty
decent all right I need to go grab a
[Music]
snack
just to go back to it the issue Barry is
like if they're holding on to those
4250 right
now and price doesn't go there all of a
sudden we have a ton of people that are
going to be selling calls um which is
not super constructive so it's kind of
like you know yeah if all of a sudden
you see them sell them sell those calls
right it's bearish on price right
now um and we're probably going to get a
bit of a move
down but I'm trying to think a little
bit about you know what the next play
[Music]
is
but yeah I mean we've been walled in
here and here nothing has happened
basically for since we started what do
we start at 1 p.m. it's been two hours
so it's like
nothing looks like they want to tap 35
[Music]
again
oh I didn't see your message J swav I
didn't realize you were in
here um how often do I do it um I just
been kind of playing it by year lately I
think I'm going to try and do it like
once a week
maybe but yeah it's pretty
fun I should also check I think
sometimes people WR in
general okay so we touched 40 again got
a little bit of a reversion off
there
but
again not much going on
here let's check
here people are figuring anything out in
general thalium is funny because he
always has he has like four windows open
with order flow for so like three order
flow charts on each window and then just
everything it's kind of insane I don't
think I could trade like that
but okay cool I think we're
good uhoh
losing 35 is not
ideal let's go back over
here oh yeah know we're okay we are okay
is setting up pretty pretty nicely
still just sometimes it takes a really
long time you know like
yeah
I feel like I want to see it
through
35 it's no coincidence right like this
is exactly where we're just
hovering it does look like they're
getting out though of these
35s but they're also getting out of the
30s right the short
30s
all right looks like we're going to
retest low of
day which again looks like it's
[Music]
seems like they're exiting here though
exiting
there
Wonder still doesn't look like we're
going to just Cascade to
me okay I guess aggregate decks on SPX
kind of does think
so
o
okay
yeah pretty decent time to try along
actually there we go right above 35
perfect pretty big note at
6050 on
ES see if we can get that if we can get
that out of the
way we can get back to the new
Range
okay yeah
probably like they did last last week
right where Friday like vix went up um
there were so many posts about that
about how spotv beta was
crazy um and it was blamed on the war
stuff like they were saying that you
know people were hedging for the for the
war
risk um all I knew was well if that's
happening there's kind of a lot of juice
out there to be squeezed soon got into
the next week beginning of the next week
all of a sudden you know know markets
move up like
crazy all right here we
go 35 shrinking getting out of
here nice good
start it's been like a waiting game like
a billion years waiting game on this
guy all
right
man I've just been um just took a second
little scalp there off
35 um it's just like beautiful little
trades that can set up here like even in
these terrible ranges where you know if
you just know where that level is and
you have
confidence you can do a little bit of
that SPX ex conversion in your
head can do a pretty decent job yeah
exactly Monday the market shot up well I
mean that's because everyone gets into
right like ball gets bid wait too much
everyone gets into the puts and then if
we don't have a massive sell off over
the weekend then they all get squeezed
like crazy because and so we shoot up um
yeah we can do I mean we can do more
series on that type of stuff that's more
like uh how would I call it like the I
like to think about it like the
seasonality of b in a way
right I mean there is a seasonality of
allall independent of that which has to
do with like VIXX expiration Cycles put
Mana rally that's a good way to put it
slot GMA put Mana rally there we go
another reason that having van is
actually kind of useful the thing is for
zero DTE after a while but like what
I've been talking about like the reason
that I'm still like bullish despite the
fact that it's like okay we're pretty
close to the low of the day it's in the
last hour all that stuff it is vaner
related right and it's hey we have all
these puts underneath us what's going to
happen with all these guys they have to
go to zero and then we have a really
nice little Hollow here to go up you
know just been waiting for it forever
because so long as people continue to be
confused
it's going to take a while and a lot of
times it does they they they um yeah I
mean it's those two things combined
right van and
charm um it looks like we are getting a
bit of our we are getting
our a bit of a move here it was kind of
cool they came down to 35 and then just
massive Wick there
right it's like I got
another message
here and I can't even tell where my oh
here we
go oh John
okay John
M all right still waiting see if they
can pop uh
maybe we'll finally have a trade to
make you know like a trade that isn't
like one or two
points J is trading today
too yeah he
is oh what a
surprise breaking above V
also a 75 that we were talking about
Peter uh that's that's vwap on
ES and it's 4250 right here uh this uh
synthetic
long so very nice little stopping place
for us for the end of the day I would
think
look at all these long calls I got added
here at 50 right over the last uh what
is that 30 minutes
actually it's like they're
preparing it's in 10 minutes It'll be
3:30 have the last half
hour
we need to get unpinned above this
40 it's being a
mess
no just that one didn't
work oil's finally having a down day
again
all right guys I don't anticipate
anything particularly exciting happening
anymore I mean like not that obviously
nothing's happened since we started but
additionally like even if we do pop up
when are we talking 15 points tops like
this is not a
uh this is not particularly fun
anymore and we're hitting about 2 hours
and 20 minutes I feel like um yeah
unless anybody has any more questions I
think I'm probably done for the day I
mean I'll leave this up or actually no
because you guys can all um get the free
trial anyway so you can watch it
yourselves um if you want to see what
happens at the end of the day yeah I
think I'm going to wrap
up yeah of course Mike I'm happy you
guys were able to hop on and and you
know I hope to improve in terms of how I
uh explain this stuff and um as more
people you know as as more people uh
start to give us feedback explain what
they see all that stuff um I I'll find
out what it is that people understand
what they don't understand and find even
better ways of uh explaining this
Allison the free trial link if you're
not already a member um if you go to
gspot.com and you go to the pricing page
it's on there yeah thank you VG
absolutely yeah thank you everybody for
showing up I appreciate it I think we
got some some good content here and
um wait so Ben you want to you want it
to keep recording until EOD
um I mean I can I guess I can I can end
the stream but keep the recording and
then uh split them up like that um I
just don't want to keep streaming
because I I I want to do some other
stuff with my
computer all right cool that sounds good
all right thanks everybody I'll see you
in the next one hopefully I'll announce
that one too